[Música]
o lado bom é que eu vim falar um pouco
sobre a escola em si porque eu não sei
estou no ensino médio do ano que vem
graças a deus acaba que pra mim foi um
período de muito sofrimento
é você muitas vezes a gente acaba apenas
pensando que a escola ela não tá
enrolando a gente eu vou para pensar
nisso
ela não está ensinando a gente está
apenas decorando a gente está apenas
gravando os números
a gente está apenas passando nas provas
que se você parar pra pensar todo todo o
conhecimento que a gente vê num não fica
eu não consigo guardar tudo que estuda
em uma escola integral sai às seis da
tarde você quer sair você quer jogar um
videogame porque já passou o dia todo na
escola e você tem que parar de estudar
eu não faço isso eu fico eu faço as
coisas que eu gosto é gosto saída da
escola eu faço um robot que eu vou isto
é jogar o jogo que eu quero você vê a
série que eu quero e acabou deixando de
lado a escola porque o eu preferir a
mesma
na minha concepção que fazer as coisas
que eu gosto é ser livre pra eu entender
me a entender na verdade é muito melhor
do que eu me matar de estudar para
passar em uma prova de 180 questões
então é isso
basicamente a gente vai falar hoje é a
gente estuda muito por exemplo a gente
tem 12 anos pra comprovar um
conhecimento em 180 questões como eu
falei como que não sei isso entra na
cabeça de vocês mas pra mim não entra
como que a gente tem 180 questões
em 12 anos eu não não tem isso se você
pegar nessas minha visão o como isso a
escola passa pra gente
basicamente
só uma metodologia de conhecimento a
gente só aprende a lógica e resolveu
resolução de problemas e acabar vendo
uma coisa só o tempo todo não importa
matéria é só a gente vai ver a matéria
vai estudar a matéria e vai replicar na
prova a gente não trabalha a gente não
desenvolve a gente não vê como tudo isso
é faz mal pra gente a gente tem tanta
coisa tenho tantas meios de comunicação
tanto a informação que a gente pode
utilizar nosso favor que eu num eu não
consigo entender como que a escola faz
isso com a gente então é decorar a gente
opta por decorar que não sei vocês
acabam uma semana de prova onde tem três
provas num dia só a gente tem uma
matéria de um de três meses para
responder em 6 ó então eu opto por
decorar tudo aquilo que eu vi o que
acaba querendo ou não eu não estudei no
aprendi tudo o que eles queriam me
passar e é isso que a gente acaba
fazendo o que acaba acontecendo aí eles
querem o nosso resultado
eles querem que a gente avance querem
que a gente dê bons números pra eles
eles querem que a gente responda à
altura que eles querem é que eles
passaram pra gente mas não é isso que a
gente quer a gente não teve a opção de
escolher o que a gente queria estudar a
gente não teve a opção de trabalhar tudo
aquilo que estava na nossa no nosso
desejo desde o começo e parece que no
fundo eles não querem que a gente se
torne mano parece que a gente quer
ou todo o conhecimento que eles querem é
só pra mais uma máquina pra eles e não é
isso a máquina tem que trabalhar pra
gente
a máquina daí pra auxiliar nossa vida
mas que não está pra tantas coisas que a
gente vê tá no nosso bolso em tudo e
parece que às vezes a gente é só mais
humano esse mundo e como seria no no
final de tudo uma escola para essa nova
metodologia para esses nova isso essas
novas pessoas que se sentem angustiados
com tudo que já
que tudo que acontece na escola como que
a gente trabalharia como em sousas onça
né
como que a gente iria resolver esse
problema
bom a escola muitos já sabem que existem
muitos anos muitas escolas seguem um
padrão mas tem algumas que tentam mudar
tudo isso eu tenho algumas que tentam
trabalhar de maneira diferente e tudo
aquilo acaba trazendo pequenos frutos
esses frutos vão se multiplicando então
uma escola que tenha uma metodologia
para trabalhar com um certo determinado
tipo de aluno é muito melhor porque o
aluno ele tem a opção de escolher aquilo
que ele quer
eu quero estudar e se gente quer uma
escola que tenha esse tempo pra
trabalhar quero eu quero ter a liberdade
de fazer tudo aquilo que é o que eu
gosto eu não quero ficar 50 minutos
vendo essa matéria e depois 50 minutos a
que a outra eu quero estudar no meu
tempo eu quero ver tudo aquilo que tem o
mundo para me oferecer
e assim a gente vai construindo a gente
vai trabalhando é impessoal os melhores
a gente vai trabalhando no que a gente
pode realmente avançar que é uma escola
melhor num ambiente mais agradável pra
gente e e trabalhando mais diversas
formas de conhecimento nossas
habilidades que quando criança a gente
tem o potencial de ser qualquer coisa
então a gente pode realmente trabalhar
do jeito que a gente quer a gente pode
transformar a gente pode é construir
resolver problemas que muitos ainda não
resolveram e acaba desenvolvendo o nosso
sentimento humanitária então a gente tem
o a escola no fundo ela tem que
trabalhar para construir o coletivo a
gente passar é ter um conteúdo mínimo
e chegar na escola para juntar para a
gente desenvolver a o nosso coletivo não
ser individualista não pensar que a eu
tô ali só para tirar um número que vai
garantir um futuro só pra mim que não
vai pensar em nos outros então o futuro
ele tá aí pra justamente a gente é
deixar de ser individualista deixar essa
parte da produção toda proibir as
máquinas se a gente pensar em nós mesmos
a gente conseguir resolver os problemas
que até hoje a gente não consegue
resolver de todo mundo é ajudar todo
mundo então é isso aí pessoal obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]